The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I wanted to
tell you a little bit
about the use of
digital communication
schemes in the space program.
And part of that is it
wasn't just the use.
A lot of coding
theory was developed
for use in this program.
So in the early days, there
was no error control coding.
So they had very slow
transmission rates
and tried to compensate
for not having
error control coding by taking
a long time to send a bit over.
But in later years, with the
Mariner and Viking probes,
they started to use
error control codes.
And linear block codes are
what we're talking about.
This would be the typical
parameters for such a code.
So we know how to read this.
This is 32 bits per block.
Six data bits.
And minimum timing
distance of 16.
A particular kind of code
called a bar orthogonal code
or Hadamard code, which had
specific characteristics
and specific symmetries
that actually
helped with the decoding.
So for instance, on
Mariner Nine, it's 1971.
This went into Mars' orbit.
And the code was used to encode
the picture transmissions.
So each data word was
six bits to encode
64 gray levels and a picture.
It turned out that, because
of transmission issues,
the safe number of bits
for a block was 30 bits.
And after that, you had to
do a little bit of realigning
or tweaking.
So you could send 30
bits at a time safely.
And so, that was a
choice of n in that
vicinity was a natural choice.
One thing you could
have thought to do
would be take the six
bits and repeat them
five times in the 30 bit window.
And that would be
a repetition code.
It turned out that, with this
particular Hadamard code,
you could actually get the same
data rates or comparable data
rates.
Let's see.
What would the data rate be?
It would be k over n, right?
6 over 32.
But with much better error
correction properties.
So let's see.
How many errors could you
correct in this code per block?
Somebody?
Seven.
Yeah.
Because you've got a minimum
Hamming distance of 16.
So you want D minus 1
over 2, the floor of that.
So you could correct up
to seven errors per block.
And this code was actually
used on space probes
right into the 80s.
And as I mentioned,
this particular code
has various symmetries that
allow actually something called
the Fast Fourier Transform
to be used in the decoding.
And so, that's really
what drove this.
As you read about these probes,
it's actually staggering
how much they did
with so little.
Let's see.
This thing went half a
billion miles almost.
It had an onboard computer
with a memory of 512 words.
So you can imagine the
kind of engineering
that went into
organizing all of this.
The transmitters-- and this is
typical of these space probes--
you don't have a lot
of energy generated
from your solar
panels necessarily.
So 20 watt transmitters.
So these have to transmit
over this kind of distance
the data that you want to
send in the presence of noise
and various other errors.
OK?
So quite an engineering feat.
Now the kinds of pictures
that you would get?
Well, these are pretty
amazing actually,
considering what the
probes had to do.
So over the lifetime, it
sent over 7,000 images.
Mariner 9 is still orbiting
Mars, from what I understand.
It's not sending back.
It stopped sending
back transmissions
one or two years after this.
But it's still in orbit until it
slows down enough to crash in.
OK.
So as I said, you're typically
talking about low power.
20 watts.
WNBR, what's a
typical radio station
power on a college campus?
They advertise
something on the order
of 700 watts for
their transmitter.
So we're talking about doing
a lot with a little here.
A lot of the art
is in the antenna.
So you have an antenna that
directs this power very sharply
towards the intended receiver.
But the more sharply
you try to direct that,
the bigger of a control
problem you have.
Because you've got to point
that antenna all that more
carefully.
So all of these
are coupled issues.
And then at the
receiver end, you've
got very high quality amplifiers
and signal processing.
But the data coding and
error correction schemes
are a key part of that.
And it turns out that,
as you got more ambitious
with these
transmissions, you had
to go to more complicated codes.
And these are the
codes we're going
to talk about today, what are
called convolutional codes.
We'll talk about
the coding today.
And then we'll talk about
the decoding with what's
called the Viterbi
algorithm next lecture.
So this has been
used extensively
from late 1970s onwards.
More recently, you have
codes that are actually
combinations of
convolutional codes, what
are called Turbo codes.
And another family of codes,
low density parity chat codes,
which were developed in Bob
Gallagher's PhD thesis here.
Bob Gallagher's on our faculty.
But convolutional codes
were really a workhorse
of the whole system.
OK.
So an example is
now Cassini, which
is in orbit around Saturn.
It's actively sending pictures.
This, if I read the
website correctly,
is a picture from August 29.
And I saw other pictures
posted from June and July.
So this is a picture of
one of Saturn's moons.
And you can see the rings
and the shadows of the rings
and so on.
This is actually
recreated in natural color
from multiple images.
This, I guess, is part picture
and part artist's rendition.
But that shows you what
Cassini looks like.
There's only one
of them out there.
I don't think there's something
else to photograph Cassini.
So the kind of code that's
used is a convolutional code.
We'll learn what
these parameters mean,
how they enter into the
definition of the code.
And here is a typical code rate.
You're talking about
something on the order
of 83,000 bits per second
as the code rate here.
Sorry, not the code rate.
This is the data rate.
OK?
So the messages are coming.
Let's see.
You're sending six times
this amount per second.
But this is the rate at
which the data is coming in.
OK?
So convolutional codes.
And again, I keep coming
back to MIT names.
Peter Elias was on
our faculty here.
He was a department
head for a while.
And in a short paper in
1955, he invented the idea
of convolutional codes.
So the idea here is not to
divide up your data into blocks
but to actually work
on the streaming data.
And as the data goes past,
you generate parity bets
at a regular rate.
And what you transmit
in most typical schemes
are just the parity bits.
You don't send the message bits.
So this would be a
non-systematic code,
if you like.
So there's no part of that
message that's directly
observing the message bits.
Now, you will actually generate
and send multiple parity bids.
So you'll have a message
sequence, x zero xn.
Sorry, x zero, x one.
And from this, you
derive parity bits.
And you do that using the
standard sorts of equations
we've seen with block codes.
Each parity bid
here, for instance,
parity bit zero at a time n
will be some linear combination
of message bits.
But it's the message bits
as they're streaming by.
So you might have, for
instance, this as your choice
for parity but number zero.
OK.
And then parity bit number one
could be some other combination
here.
So for instance, xn plus
x n minus 2, for instance.
OK.
So it's a linear combination
of some set of messages, just
the way we've been generating
parity bits all along.
The plus here, of
course, is we're
talking about binary messages.
So this is addition in GF2.
So it's exclusive or
Modulo 2 addition.
And you can imagine a whole
bunch of such parity bits.
So in general, you would have
R such parity bits computed off
some set of message bits
and transmitted instead
of the message bits.
So you might have, for each
message been coming in,
you might actually be
sending out R parity bits.
So what you do is just
send these out in sequence.
You'd send out the P zero
value, the P1 value, time n.
Then recompute a time n
plus 1 and keep going.
All right?
Well, actually I have them here.
I didn't see that.
So all this happens
on a sliding window.
This happens for a
particular choice of n.
And then it happens for
the next choice of n
and the next choice of n.
So you're doing this on the
fly with a streaming sequence.
So let me just
put up an equation
that explains why this is
called a convolutional code.
It turns out the expressions
of this type where
you take a data stream coming
in and generate new data
streams of this
form, it turns out
that the operation that's
being carried out here
is something referred
to as convolution.
So in general, what
has P zero then?
It's some weighted combination
of x at the current time,
x1 times step back,
x2 time steps back.
In general, k different
values involved.
So what I have is a P zero
n being a summation from,
let's say, J equals zero.
So G zero J x of n
minus J. All right?
So this is just
some set of numbers.
Zero, one.
Just as these bits are,
these are zero, one.
But this is the general form.
This particular
kind of combination
is referred to as a convolution
operation on the input stream.
And we'll see much
more of this when
we come later to
modeling channels,
the physical channels.
We'll talk about
convolution type models.
So here, it's not so
important that you
must have this expression.
We'll have plenty of
opportunity to work
with expressions like this.
This is just for you to
know that an expression
of this type, wherever you
see a summation with indices
that are in this form, this is
referred to as a convolution.
OK?
So it's convolution
of the message stream
with some set of weights.
AUDIENCE: Professor?
PROFESSOR: Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What does G stand for?
PROFESSOR: The G is just
a set of weights here.
So in this particular case,
for parity expression zero,
G zero of zero would be 1.
G zero of 1 would be 1.
G zero of 2 would be 1.
AUDIENCE: OK.
PROFESSOR: It's just
a set of weights.
So yeah.
This expression is a bit of
overkill for the kind of use
we're making of it.
But it's just to explain
the origin of the name.
It turns out later, when we
use it for channel modeling,
the x's will not just
be zeros or ones.
They could take
arbitrary real values.
And the Gs could take
So we'll be working with
much more elaborate versions
of this.
OK?
The number k is referred to
as the constraint length.
And it's the maximum number
of message bits involved
when you look over all
your parity expressions.
So in this particular instance,
k would be equal to 3.
Right?
It's the maximum window
of data that you're
using in a non-trivial
way to generate the bits.
So here, you are using
up to 3 to generate this.
Well, in this case
also, you're using
a window of three message bits.
It happens that you're
ignoring the one in the center.
But the constraint length
is the length of message
that you're actually looking at.
OK.
So in some sense, if you
want to think of it this way,
the number of parity
expressions that you use?
Well, that's straightforward.
That's just telling
you how much redundancy
you're willing to put in.
Whereas the constraint
length is telling you
how deeply you're folding that
redundancy into the message.
So the bigger the
constraint length,
the more message
bits are involved
in generating a parity bit.
And so, the more you're
scrambling up the message
and spreading it over a large
section of what's transmitted.
And so, you might
expect that you
get a better error correction
properties with larger
constraint links.
OK?
OK.
This is not saying anything new.
So how do we come to
actually transmitting?
Well, we generate
the parity bits.
And then, as I said, you
send all the parity bits
associated with your
computation at time zero.
Then all the parity bits
associated with the computation
at time 1, time 2, and so on.
So in the case of the code
used on the Cassini probe,
that's 1 over 6 rate code.
It's actually computing
six parity expressions.
So it's transmitting
six parity bits
for each message
bit that comes in.
What happens then at
the next time instant
is that you shift
everything up by one.
And we do the whole thing.
OK?
Now, you can actually-- and I'll
have this up on the slides--
you can actually crank
through the equations.
But it's not the
most illuminating way
to think of things.
It's much easier to think of
it visually through a block
diagram of this type and
using the idea of what's
called a shift register.
So what is a shift register?
You may have encountered
it in other places.
So we think of a shift register
as, it's basically a box that
can remember something.
OK?
That's the register part of it.
A register is something
that remembers a number.
You've got some input
stream that comes in
and some output stream emerging.
At any time, this stores
a particular number which
is available to the output.
So whatever is stored
in the register
is available to the output.
The shift part of
this description
is that whatever is
of the input will
get shifted into at the next
clock cycle or the next time
instance.
OK?
So the input gets shifted
in at the next clock cycle.
Whatever is in here is
remembered for that one clock
cycle and is available
at the output.
Right?
So if I have a sequence x n
being fed in four n zero, one,
two, three, and so on,
if I'm seeing x n here,
what must have gone
into the previous time?
If I see x n here at time n, if
I'm seeing a particular input
at time n, what must have
gone in the previous time
as x n minus 1?
So what's sitting
here is x minus 1.
Right?
And x n minus 1 is available
to me at the output.
The next clock cycle, the
next input comes along.
The xn goes in here.
And the whole thing shifts.
All right?
Now what you have up there is
a cascade of shift registers.
You've got some shift registers.
So keep in mind, the
operation that I described--
if this is xn, if I'm looking
at this time at time n,
xn sitting here--
what must be in
this shift register
is the input of
the previous time.
So that's x n minus 1.
These are shown adjacent.
What we really mean is
that one shift register
is feeding into the next one.
They're just shown as adjacent.
But what must be sitting
here then is x n minus 2.
And if I read off something
from here, what I'm looking at
is x n minus 1.
Namely, what's sitting
in the register.
What I'm looking at
here is x n minus 2.
All right.
So do you see how
this is working now?
This is actually
the same example
that I had written
up earlier, I guess,
for the computational
parity bit.
So here's-- except it's--
yeah.
It's the same one.
P zero n.
Maybe I have the equations.
Let's see if I can
display them for you.
No, I can't.
OK.
So what's P zero n?
P zero n is xn, that's
connecting from here,
plus x n minus 1
plus x n minus 2.
Again, by the way,
in this diagram, what
I showed as an arrow coming
from the output of the shift
register is just
a shorthand here
that shows the arrow coming out
from the body of the register.
It's the same thing
we're talking about.
OK?
So P zero of n is the sum
of these three message bits.
So we're talking one
constraint length three here.
And what about P1 n?
It's xn plus x n minus 2
with nothing of xn minus 1.
All right?
So imagine this being
the picture for every n.
So you start off at time
zero and keep going.
Right?
We refer to the
state of the shift
registers as the pair of
numbers that we find in here.
So if we're talking about x's
that can be zeros or ones,
the shift register
combination here
can be in one of four states.
Right?
Zero, zero.
Zero, 1.
1, zero.
Or 1, 1.
So four states.
So here's a four state
shift register into which
we're feeding in the stream.
And what gets put
out on the channel
are these parity
bits interleaved.
That clear enough?
OK.
Nothing I haven't said here.
Right?
So let's actually work through
an example step by step.
This is clear enough.
But let's just
see it concretely.
Let's assume that I'm
starting out with the shift
registers in the zero state.
And now, I've got this
message sequence coming in
that I want to send out.
OK?
So the sequence
is 1, zero, 1, 1.
So the first bit that
appears here is the 1.
And I've got to
generate P zero and P1.
Well, P zero is the exclusive
OR of these three things.
So it's 1.
P1 is the exclusive OR of
the first and the last.
So it's again 1.
So that defines P
zero and P1 at time n.
The same way at the next time
instant, the next message input
bit comes in.
So we had 1, zero, 1, 1.
We took care of the 1 here.
Now comes a zero.
We do the same thing.
So the exclusive OR of all
three of them appears here.
That's the 1.
The exclusive OR of the first
and the last appears there.
And that's the zero.
So you can see how things
are getting folded together
because the input that was here
before is now sitting in here
and plays a role in
generation of the parity
bit for the next step.
In fact, the word convolve
means to fold together.
And this is what it's
actually trying to capture.
You're folding
together these two sets
of weights, the weights on the
top tier and the input sequence
weight.
And then the next
two cases, similarly.
OK.
And that's what gets
sent out at the bottom.
So this is the
transmitted sequence.
So it's the 11100001.
Right?
That's all there is to it.
The implementation of the
shift register is very easy.
And so, this is actually a
very straightforward thing
to implement.
Now there's another viewpoint
that's also very useful here.
Another way to look
at what's going on,
which is thinking in terms
of the state of the register
and how you move
between the states.
I guess, how many here are 004?
Are those are the ones
with smiles on their faces?
OK.
You see a lot of this
there, I imagine.
OK.
So how do I read a
diagram like this?
I've got a circle for each
state that the shift register
can be in.
So the shift register
can be in zero, zero.
Zero, 1.
1, zero.
1, 1.
Right?
Each of these arcs
represents a transition
from one state to another.
So let me ask you this.
What does it take--
if I'm in the zero,
zero state with my shift
register-- so what
you've got in the picture
is your shift register
sitting there with zero, zero.
What does it take for me to
get to the 1, zero state?
What must my input have been
to get to the 1, zero state?
Imagine how these shift
registers operate.
Right?
If I'm going to get from
zero, zero to 1, zero,
I must have fed in a 1 at
the previous time instance.
So it takes an input of 1 to go
from zero, zero to the 1, zero.
So to go from zero, zero to
1, zero, use an input of 1.
That's the number that we
write before the slash.
That's our labeling
convention for the arcs.
We put the input that it
takes to make that transition.
And then after the slash,
we put the parity bits
that are omitted.
So what we've got
for the 1, 1 is
the parity bits that are omitted
when you've got input 1 sitting
here, zero, zero here, and
you're using the parity
computation that I had before.
Let's see here.
So P zero is going to
be x n plus x n minus 1
plus x n minus 2.
So that gives you 1.
And what about P1?
P1 is x n plus xn minus 2.
So that gives you another one.
OK?
So if you're in state zero--
the zero, zero state--
and you get an
input of 1, you're
going to transition to 1, zero.
And you're going to omit 1, 1.
OK.
So the state diagram
captures all that.
And similarly, all
the way around.
So I haven't checked
each of these.
But I hope there are
no mistakes in it.
But if you're in 1, zero?
Oh well.
By the way, if
you're in zero, zero,
there's no way to
get to zero, 1.
Right?
So you don't see any arc
from zero, zero to zero, 1.
If you're in 1, zero,
you can get to 1, 1.
Or you can get to zero, 1
depending on what you feed in.
OK?
So it's very
straightforward, then,
to actually build
out this diagram.
Why don't we do a
little bit more on here?
OK.
So if I'm actually abstracting
from the shift register picture
to something that's more
like the state picture,
I'm going to say, here
are my four states.
I've just drawn it a
little differently than I
have in the upper picture.
Instead of circles with
these states in them,
I prefer to think
of them this way.
So what we said is, if you get
an input of 1, you limit 1, 1.
And you'll get to that state.
What does it take
to get to the state?
Somebody?
Can I have a hand
and a loud voice?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Input zero.
PROFESSOR: OK.
And then I guess you've got
to go back to this to think
about what's happening.
So I'll allow you to think of a
zero sitting at the input here.
So what would the
parity bits be?
So the first parity bit
will be the exclusive OR
of the zero, 1, and zero.
So it's going to give you a 1.
Right?
And then the next
parity bit is going
to be exclusive OR of
what's here and there.
So that's going to be a zero.
I hope that matches with
what I have upstairs.
We're talking about going
from 1, zero to zero, 1.
It takes a zero
input to do that.
And what you omit is 1, zero.
Right?
So you can fill in all of these.
This is the state
transition diagram.
OK.
Let's see.
We say that, if you've got
a constraint length of three
then, of k equals
three, for instance,
or let's say if you've got
a constraint length of k,
you've got 2 to the
k minus 1 states.
well, that's because, in
that constraint length,
one of the bits involved
is the input bit.
That's not sitting in
the shift registers.
So you've got k minus
1 bits left over.
So your shift register
is k minus 1 stages long.
And so, you've got 2 to
the k minus 1 states.
All right.
So you could imagine
generalizing this
to more complicated
sorts of situations.
Let's see.
Just going back to
the Cassini example,
if you let me jump back a
bit, there was a k there.
What was it?
k of 15.
OK.
So for Cassini, you're using
one input bit and 14 more
bits in your register.
OK?
So you've got 2 to the
14 possible states there.
So in these codes,
you're actually
using very large
constraint lengths.
OK.
All right.
I want to go from the state
machine view to another view
now, which is what's called--
so this is the state machine
view--
to something called
the trellis view.
This is something--
by the way, there
was a way of looking
at things that
was developed by someone else
who was on our faculty, David
Forni.
In fact, if you visit his
home, you'll see his garden.
There's a nice
trellis around it.
And you'll see why
when we draw this.
OK.
So what's the trellis view?
The trellis view says
take the state machine
but unfold it in time so that
all your transitions over time
are not happening here.
At every time step, you
draw the picture again
and look to see
where you get to.
So let's do this.
This is the one I want
to be most careful with
and where I'll introduce a
few notational conventions so
that our later
life is simplified.
OK.
So we've got state zero, zero.
State zero, 1.
State 1, zero.
And state 1, 1.
OK.
Except, though, this is
going to be the picture
that I have at time--
let's say-- at
time n equals zero.
At time n equals 1, well, I've
got the same shift registers.
I'm going to draw
this picture again.
The easiest way to learn
this is to just follow
through one example.
So please keep your
attention here.
And you'll have it sorted out.
And then you won't have
to worry about it again.
It's the same thing as with LZW.
All right.
So it looks kind of detailed.
Maybe tedious.
But it's actually very simple.
Just hang in there and
follow through one example.
OK.
So what does this say?
At time n equals zero,
I'm in zero, zero.
Suppose I get the input zero.
Suppose the input is zero.
What state do I transition to?
Here.
Right?
So if I have an input zero,
I'm going to transition here.
So this is with
an input of zero.
And what are my parity
bits going to be?
Both zeros.
Right?
What about if I get
an input of one?
Where do I transition to?
Well, we've already
seen that here.
If I get an input of 1, I'm
going to transition to here.
And what am I going to omit?
Well, we've already
calculated that.
We're going to omit a 1, 1.
Right?
Let's do it for one more case.
We're in zero, 1.
What states can I transition to?
I could go to zero, zero.
And I would do that
if my input was zero.
Right?
And what would my
parity bits be?
Well, that's another
case for us to look at.
If our input is zero and
we're in state zero, 1,
what would the parity bits be?
For this choice of parity bits,
depends on what specific choice
you made, of course.
1, 1?
Do you agree?
And if I get an input of
1 instead, where do I go?
If I get an input
of 1, I'm going
to go to 1, zero, which is here.
OK?
So if I had an input of
1, I would go to 1, zero.
My parity bits would be--
what would they be?
Can I have a hand and a voice?
Yeah.
Zero, zero.
Right.
OK.
So it's that simple.
That's all you have to do.
Fill out this picture
and you're seeing
what this picture translates
to at the next time instant.
We're not using
anything more than is
in the state transition--
sorry-- in the state
machine diagram.
But we're unfolding
things in time,
which is actually very helpful.
Now, this is a simplification
we'll make in drawing this.
Because I've arranged the
states in natural binary
counting order--
zero zero, zero
1, 1 zero, and 1,
1-- it's always the case
that the upper arrow that
emanates from a
state corresponds
to the input of zero.
And the lower corresponds
to an input of one.
OK?
So I don't really need that
first thing before the dash.
I'm just going to
dispense with it.
So if you're going up, of
the two choices that you
have when you come out of a box,
if you're going up, it's zero.
The input is zero.
And if you're going
down, the input is 1.
So I'm just going to
label that as zero, zero.
OK?
I'm going to label this as 1, 1.
And I guess I've forgotten
already what some of these are.
But you can see what the whole
picture starts to look like.
OK?
So let me actually, I'm not
going to do these in detail.
But let's just see how the next
stage would differ, if at all.
When I come to n
equals 2, well, it's
the same story all over again.
So whatever pattern of arrows
I had coming out of here,
I have the same pattern
at the next stage
with the same labels.
Right?
Because there's
nothing different.
So if you'll allow
me, let me actually
fill out a few of these.
And you'll get
practice drawing one
of these when you do recitation
maybe for another example.
So I can keep going with these.
Let's see here.
This is going to be 1, 1.
If I haven't found two arrows
coming out of each box,
then I'm not done.
Oh, this is wrong.
Right?
Thank you.
From zero, 1, I
can go to 1, zero.
OK.
So the two arrows coming out
of each one, the upper arrow
corresponds to the
input having been zero.
The lower arrow corresponds
to an input having been 1.
And there are two arrows
going into each box,
as well, corresponding
to whether the bit that's
going to get dropped
off is a zero or a 1.
All right?
So there's a real
symmetry to this.
I'll draw one more
stage just a little bit
to make a point here.
OK.
So you can keep going.
So how do you generate a code
word from a trellis diagram?
You're starting in some state.
Typically, it's
the all zero state.
In fact, what
you'll usually do is
have a header for your message
stream which is all zero.
So you force the shift register
to be in the zero state
once the real
message bits come in.
And then you move from here.
So you're typically
starting here.
And then you navigate,
depending on whether you've
got a zero or a 1.
So if the first
message bit is a 1,
you're going to go down here.
If the next message
bit is a zero,
you're going to go up here.
If the next message
bit is a zero,
you're going to go up there.
And the code word that
you omit is going to be,
in that case, 1,
1, 1, zero, 1, 1.
And then all zeros.
Right?
Assuming you're staying
at zero from then on.
So depending on what
the message sequence is,
you can actually go
through the trellis.
It's infinitely long, or as long
as your message sequence is.
And figure out what the
code word is that's omitted.
So this is actually
just a graphical way
of displaying code words.
So the set of code
words that I get,
does that correspond
to a linear code?
Let's assume that, somewhere
downstream, all these things
come back down to zero, zero.
OK?
So I'm only considering a
finite window of things.
It's not going to go on forever.
So suppose I'm going to end
my input messages with zero,
zero at the end and come
back down to that state.
So my messages will always
start with zero, zero
to force the register
to the zero, zero state.
And they'll end with zero, zero.
OK?
The set of possible code
words is a set of parity bits
I omit along the way as I
navigate through the trellis.
Is the set of code words,
does the set of code words
constitute a linear code?
That's the question.
Maybe not obvious.
Right?
The way you answer
that is actually
thinking back to this setting.
So one particular
code word would
correspond to a particular input
sequence that generated it.
A particular data message
Another code would correspond
to another message sequence.
And the question is, is
there a message sequence
that would generate the
sum of these two code words
that you have?
And actually, it turns
out that the answer is yes
because these parity
relationships are based
on a nice linear operation.
OK?
So it turns out that the set
of code words that you generate
constitutes a linear code.
So if you were going to
think of a minimum Hamming
distance for this
code, what would you
want to be thinking of?
I don't know if I've actually
drawn this correctly right now.
Has anyone spotted any
errors along the way?
Or do I have it right?
Seems to be OK.
What would, how would you
look for a minimum Hamming
distance in the set of
code words generated
over this window?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
I didn't hear where
that came from.
Yeah.
Can you speak up?
The minimum number of ones
in a non-zero code word.
Right?
So it would be the weight,
the minimum weight code
word you'd find among all
the number of code words.
So you would have to find
a path starting here.
All my code words are going
to start here and there.
You have to find a path
through this that picks up
the minimum number of ones.
A path that's different
from the all zeros path.
OK?
Find a path through there which
has the minimum number of ones
in it and the code word.
So what would that be?
In this particular
case, maybe this path
we highlighted in another color.
I don't have-- this
is not a proof.
This is just a suggestion
that this might be it.
And you would have to
draw in all the paths,
explore all the other paths.
But what would be the minimum
weight along this one?
Let's see.
I've got 1, 1 there.
1, zero here.
1, 1 there.
So I would get a weight
of 5 on this path.
Now the question is whether
you could find another path
with a smaller number of ones
attached to the code word.
And I think if you work this
out in detail on [INAUDIBLE],,
that you'll find that you're
actually stuck with 5.
OK?
Now it turns out that the
interpretation of this number
is not quite as straightforward
as the interpretation
of the minimum Hamming
distance in block codes.
And the reason is
that actually this
is a more complicated
kind of picture
because it continues
on with the structure.
So we don't actually call it
the minimum Hamming distance.
We call it the free distance.
So I'm just trying
to evoke this.
So the minimum
weight code word you
find among the
non-zero code words
will indeed be a
code word of eight 5.
But the interpretation
of that number
may not be directly as simple
as in the case of the Hamming
distance.
But it's close.
OK?
So what it really
tells you is that,
over a data length
that is maybe not
much longer than
this, the code words
that you have are separated
by this distance minimum.
So you might expect that you
could correct two bit errors
over data lengths
that correspond
to code words that are somewhat
longer than this perhaps.
OK?
So that's all very hand-wavy.
But that's all we're going
to do with the notion
of free distance.
So this is more complicated to
deal with than a block code.
But the free distance actually
has that kind of intuition.
It has the intuition of
minimum Hamming distance
locally over this
window of data.
Even if this went on
for thousands of bits,
if you got a burst of
errors in this stretch that
had up to two errors,
you could correct them.
Now we haven't talked
about decoding.
We're going to talk
about that the next time.
OK.
So that answers this piece.
Now let me say one thing
about decoding, just
to set us up for next time.
If I didn't have any
noise in my channel,
it actually turns out that
decoding is pretty trivial.
How is that?
If I gave you the
sequence of parity bits,
can you think of a way that
you could recover the input
sequence?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: Good.
Yeah.
You see, if I add these two, I
get x n minus 1 equals P zero
n plus P1 n.
So if you give me the
parity bit stream,
I can reconstruct for
you exactly the input
with a one step delay.
That's pretty good.
I'm happy with that.
If it's taken me minutes for the
signal to reach me from Saturn,
I'm happy with a one step
delay here in decoding.
All right?
So in the absence of noise,
the inversion is simple.
The inversion meaning deducing
the input message bits
from the output,
the parity bits.
And this is a theme you'll
see in many other settings.
If there's no noise,
inversion is easy.
You can look at the
output of a system
and figure out
what the input was.
If you know exactly how
the system was creating
the output from the input.
But in the presence of
noise, you've got a problem.
Because you see, if
you have these parity
bits corrupted at some rate--
every few bits,
you've got errors--
well, you're
interpreted message is
going to have that same
kind of error rate.
OK?
So it's really, in
the presence of noise,
it's an unsatisfactory
way to do it.
So this doesn't work.
We'll be looking at something
more careful next time.
OK?
So well actually,
since I have you here,
let me put up the spot quiz.
We haven't quite hit the mark.
So can you answer these for me?
What's the constraint
length of this code?
Anyone?
Who hasn't answered?
Yeah?
4.
Right?
Because you've got xn and
xn minus 1, xn minus 2,
xn minus 3.
That's the largest window over
which you're picking things.
What about the code rate?
1 over 3?
Right?
Because for every
message bit, you're
generating three parity bits.
You're going to shift
out those three parity
bits before you do the
shifting on the shift register.
So the code rate is 1 over 3.
The coefficients
of the generators,
of course, you
can read up there.
What about the number of states
in the state machine here?
What?
8.
Right?
Because constraint length is 4.
But one of those is the input.
So you've got three bits that
you're storing in memory.
2 to the 3 is 8.
So the number of states
in the machine is 8.
OK?
So more complicated
picture than this.
But the same principle.
All right.
We'll continue next time.